when you're writing a screenplay do you
ever think about the money you'll make
off of it as you're writing it
no because
i already have a contract so i know
now a spec yeah you can have illusions
of grandeur you know as much as you want
but after
years in the business you know the
realities of like okay but no you
shouldn't
you shouldn't write from a place of that
you should forget about all that like i
say you should do
your best job ever if you're paid 500
bucks or you're paid 5 million bucks
there should be no
no difference in in your
desire because then what are you doing
you're chasing money there's other
businesses to do that that are
that are far more lucrative than
spending
you know years of your life toiling away
and trying to have that one
this is the one that's going to do it
you know
so um no you should just bathe in the
creative process and not
you know it's when you're writing your
specs
when you're writing an assignment you
already have a contract you know what
you're making so
and then it becomes you know stressful
because you're actually making something
so you're like oh shoot this is do when
this better be good you know this is
what they're paying me for
so that comes at a different level you
know when you leap over into that
other realm of working like we discussed
earlier about
um being creative under a deadline than
just toiling away you can
work it's great to work when you want
you know you know my spec i'm just doing
you know this and
there's no nobody else not working with
anybody else
this is all my words which it has to be
to get to a certain point
absolutely but then you step over that
line into the other world
and it's like well we don't like the
ending and then the nam about and it
becomes
you know like they say filmmaking is a
million um
compromises to get something done and
sadly yeah
but to get something done is amazing
and does that go back to what we're
talking about with the tai chi
or the the karate example which is
part of it's the physical and part of
it's the mental and maybe that pressure
of like
i've got to be creative and i've got a
deadline and
not not cracking under that pressure
sure
it's uh a lot of it i mean tremendous
amount of his mental
you know but then those disciplines you
can fall back on
not straight because you can get into
this terrible wheel
that you're not producing at the best
level you can because you're too worried
about
the other thing if you just trust
yourself and
dive into the work you'll get it done
you know if you're not constantly
worried about well i got eight days left
you know just do it